hey guys I'm Erik Bosse and I've been
rewatching one of my favorite superhero
movies of 2016
Deadpool and here at new rockstars we've
been talking about our favorite antihero
movies all this month Kyle just made a
video about Suicide Squad that you
should definitely check out but me I
love Deadpool and based on how much you
guys are still tweeting us about this
movie so do you and yeah I know it's
been a while since it came out and by
now a lot of you have probably caught
all the obvious references but I
realized that there's actually a lot
more to this movie than people really
covered when you compare the final cut
to the early drafts of the script listen
to the commentaries look at the deleted
scenes and watch this movie over and
over as endlessly as I have some really
cool miscible details start to emerge so
I'm gonna break all of those down
skipping over some of the obvious stuff
that you've probably already caught
we're gonna see exactly how many layers
Deadpool has so let's get started so the
movie's opening title sequence is just
fantastic it's full of little winks like
the actors names being replaced with the
stereotypical roles that they play and
in the coffee cup with Rob Elle that's
for Rob Liefeld the co-creator of the
Deadpool comics of course the Ryan
Reynolds Green Lantern photo yada yada
yada but I want to talk about the visual
design of the scene so the writers said
that this sequence of characters frozen
and mid action as the camera swoops
around them that is an homage to Adam
burns award-winning carousel ad for
Philips check out it has some of the
same awesome visuals and notice how the
first shot we see of Deadpool it's his
crotch like the first impression we get
a Deadpool is him teabag in the audience
that is a bold promise for the
irreverent humor that this movie's gonna
have I gotta say I have never been so
thrilled to be a teabag before all right
moving on now check out this shot of
Deadpool in his suit riding a taxi
that's a funny visual that grounds a
superhero immediately it's kind of like
that scene at the beginning of
spider-man 2 and Peter has to ride a
crappy moped and take the elevator it's
really fun to force superheroes to take
mundane forms of transportation and of
course deadpool and spiderman actually
have a ton of connections in the Marvel
comics so it's really cool to see the
movie use these references to bring them
together in fact an early draft of the
script
Deadpool's mask was supposed to be a
store-bought spider-man mask turned
inside out that's interesting because in
the early days development of Deadpool
he was conceived as the darker amoral
flipside the jokey hero that Spiderman
was to the Marvel Universe and real
quick I just want to point this out
because I think this is a really
fascinating detail dopinder the taxi
driver was named after a kid Ryan
Reynolds went to school with who got
struck by lightning and yeah that's
super tragic but come on getting struck
by lightning and getting a Deadpool
character named after you that's a much
cooler legacy than being the kid who
threw up on himself also you may have
noticed Deadpool's obsession with
Christmas in this movie and I'm after
someone on my naughty list that's
because the original script had a very
different storyline that involved
Francis going to prison and get him
released on Christmas Day that's the day
Deadpool counts down to to get his
revenge I'll talk more later about how
and why that was changed moving on to
this introduction of Francis aka Ajax
now the final cut of the movie
established him as the arms dealer and
head of Weapon X labs even though
originally he was supposed to be more of
a supporting villain but there's another
reason why this scene was changed check
out this deleted scene that the final
version replaced this is Francis getting
released from prison and not just any
prison
that's the raft now the raft is a prison
for superhumans from the Marvel comics
but remember the MCU ended up showing
the raft in Captain America's Civil War
and since Deadpool is technically part
of a movie universe that's separate from
the MCU Marvel probably instructed them
to hold off showing this ultimate
version of a Marvel property we actually
go into this in other videos why certain
things and characters from comics can't
appear together in the movies like why
the Fantastic Four couldn't be in the
Civil War the movies even though they're
in it in the comics it's because Fox
owns them and they prefer to put them in
really bad movies okay let's move on to
this overpass freeway sequence which is
a recreation of that test footage that
Ryan Reynolds leaked to help get the
movie made director Tim Miller said that
they didn't just reuse the same footage
both scenes were made separately from a
source script and then the final cut
since they had more money now could get
closer to what the writers wanted so for
example check out how hollaback girl
with me
was updated to salt-n-pepa's shoot I
wanna shoot baby shoot came out in the
year 1993 which is the same year
Deadpool solo series debuted making it
more of a contemporary reference then we
see more of this great action sequence
and I just want to point out that this
one freeway scene provides the entire
narrative backbone of this movie the
first 40 minutes stays right here with
flashbacks that cutaways breaking it up
now there's a few reasons for that for
one this movie had a budget of only 58
million dollars that is pocket change
compared to the 250 million that civil
war and Batman vs Superman guy there
were also only a lot of the shooting
schedule of 48 days that's about a month
shorter than most big action movies get
to shoot so keeping this one set as the
location for most of the movie makes
budgetary sense but it also gives the
movie an interesting pace and story
structure unlike any we've seen in a
superhero movie before so what do you
think about origin stories like Iron Man
Captain America Batman Begins spider-man
writer man again probably spider-man a
third time they all rely on similar
story beats that occur in the same order
sympathetic hero undergoes
transformation makes a bold entrance and
spinni newspapers sweep the nation well
a Deadpool is not chronological it
starts in the action in this great
freeway sequence like the test footage
promised it would be and then it lets
his origin gradually unfold via
flashbacks so we don't spend half the
movie waiting for Wade Wilson to finally
become Deadpool the movie balances out
the fun Deadpool action that we want to
see with the grounded Wade Wilson
character beets that we need in order to
care about the story now I should say
that Suicide Squad actually tried to use
the same device to retroactively Lee
endow their anti heroes with humanity
but I don't think it worked out quite as
well and I'll get to why later anyway
before I move on yes there were a ton of
Easter eggs here all the street signs
referencing names like Peter Parker and
baby in the chaser and all the visual
effects artists to work on the movie and
then of course a quick clip of the Adam
West Batman the music on the radio this
man
but one of my favorite jokes is actually
cut from the movie so check out when
Deadpool burns this guy's poor head with
the cigarette lighter originally the
joke was gonna be loved your work and
daredevil referencing bullseye who has a
similar scar on his forehead the writer
has decided to cut it because they
thought it was a little too inside
baseball for general audiences but not
too inside for us moving on to this
cutaway seen at the x-men mansion
originally this scene wasn't in the
movie but Tim Miller went and shot it
and then added it to the final cut
because test audiences weren't familiar
enough with colossus and negasonic
teenage warhead to know that they're
part of the good guys I'll talk more
about Colossus later but negasonic
originally wasn't in the script either
the writers added her to be a younger
foil to Colossus and Deadpool they
actually got a list of approved obscure
heroes for Marvel and they just love the
name negasonic teenage warhead so much
that they decided to use her in the
movie and had to get special permission
to change her powers though
Deadpool's 12 shot countdown is one of
my favorite parts of this movie it's
just so great another than that final
Frances shot of the movie it's the only
time that Deadpool uses a gun as his
primary weapon the writers of the movie
said that they liked Deadpool as a hero
who uses katanas and his fists so if
there is a shootout they wanted to make
it count literally count limiting
Deadpool to a precise number of bullets
now there's some amazing shot
composition here that I got to point out
first check out this shot at the bullet
hole through Deadpool's arm this is the
same angle from a scene in Shaun of the
Dead and it's such a great way to show
that putting holes in this person does
not kill them also notice how Deadpool's
katanas swarm an X through the thugs
body so Deadpool is so resistant to
joining the x-men he actually makes fun
of the whole idea of the x-men over and
over again through the movie the day I
decide to become a crime-fighting Swizz
ler who rooms with a bunch of other
little whiners at the neverland mansion
on that day I'll send your shiny happy
ass a friend request yet still he keeps
being surrounded by this subliminal
imagery that's like calling him to join
the x-men and be a hero more than an
antihero now before I get to the pizza
delivery scene check out this one edit
that gets us there we jump cut from a
close-up of Deadpool zas to this
bedazzled Jean ass of this other guy and
the writer stroke this was their ask to
ask transition which is a super deep cut
to the movie requiem for a dream
[Music]
I also like that this movie is making
fun of the weird obsession with butts
that past superhero movies have had he
has those tights in that tight little
hmm
love you what the big deal is uh moving
on okay so obviously this pizza scene is
taken directly out of the comics issue
number 10 from the 2008 Deadpool run a
lot of you spotted the famous Maggie's
pizza box referencing Marvel head Kevin
Feige also the Bea Arthur shirt that
Wade is wearing but this next scene in
the skate park that I want to point out
notice how Wade refuses to beat up the
other girl's stepdad just because she
doesn't like him and then later he tells
weasel to give the girl back her money
so this flashback isn't just depicting
Wade as a wisecracking Merc with the
mouth it's also making him out to be a
good guy with a heart so let's quickly
point out a few things about this sister
Margaret's bar robbed light though makes
a quick cameo I felt hey wait then wait
and weasel reference a line from x-men
origins all I ever wanted was to travel
far-off exotic places meet new and
exciting people and then kill them I was
traveling to exotic places needing new
and exciting people killing them yeah
I've seen your Instagram which is one of
the many nods to the awful depiction of
Deadpool that the studio made Ryan
Reynolds do and if you want to know the
names of everyone in the deaf pool on
the blackboard you can pause and read
them now shockingly all these people are
still alive but there was one running
gag in the original script that was cut
because the person did Amy Winehouse now
several cutaways throughout the film
were supposed to show Winehouse very
close to death but miraculously avoiding
it until finally in the final shot of
the movie she was supposed to get run
over by a London double-decker bus yeah
that probably would have come off is a
little too dark a few years after she
died of alcohol poisoning now let's move
on to Vanessa the way the character
Vanessa was adapted from the comics and
even from the early draft of the script
is a big part of what makes this movie
so good of course in the comics Vanessa
is just a prostitute that wade hooks up
with who later becomes the
shape-shifting superhero copycat now the
studio and the creative team hasn't
acknowledged yes or no on whether the
movie version of Vanessa will become
copycat in the sequels but
this version of Vanessa is definitely a
more fleshed out character John more
wise this movie is mainly a love story
other superhero movies have had love
stories as subplots but Deadpool puts it
front and center and Vanessa is the
character that drives all of that this
flirty one-upping moment between Wade
and Vanessa is just great writing my
childhood rougher than yours daddy left
before I was born
daddy left before I was conceived ever
had a cigarette put out on your skin
where else do you put one out it's
actually the part of the script that
they used to audition actresses to play
the role of Vanessa Tim Miller said that
he saw Olivia Munn read for the part and
she was the front-runner
until she backed out to play psylocke in
x-men apocalypse hopefully at least the
pay was better and I want to point out
that this whole premise is actually a
reference to the classic Monty Python
sketch called the four Yorkshiremen
take a look House look well when I say
house it was just a hole in the ground
covered by a sheet of tarpaulin but it
was a house to us we were evicted from
our all in the ground we had to go and
live in a lake now check out this
transition to way too Vanessa in arcade
at first the shot is horizontal like
they're having sex but no the next shot
reveals that they're just on a sweet
date that's an inside joke to the fact
that originally the script was gonna
jump from the bar to them screwing but
the writers wanted to seem to show Wade
and Vanessa developing as a couple
rather than just the purely
transactional relationship that they had
in the comics moving on to this
amazingly raunchy Calendar Girl montage
which the writers and the director said
was the hardest sequence to pull off
they really wanted it to be about the
jokes happy led it's not about the
poorni visuals and the writers said that
this is probably the first superhero
movie to show someone getting pegged
No and I tried to fact-check that but
there's a lot of things I can't unsee
now they actually end up having to cut
this entire sequence from the film for
Chinese audiences because Chinese censor
board's kept giving them notes and
they're like you know what this isn't
gonna make sense we just have to take it
out and one of the ideas that they ended
up not using was to have Easter sex with
wait in the yellow chicken costumes a
chocolate egg on Venessa stomach which
would be hilarious but yeah probably a
little too extreme also just in case you
didn't catch this during the lent
abstinence beat check out what book wait
is reading it's Mario Lopez's memoir
that's a reference to the April Fool's
joke that Deadpool did with Mario Lopez
revealing that the movie would be
r-rated but again this story needs us to
care about Wade and Vanessa's
relationship so notice how quickly it
progresses they celebrate the holidays
together
Wade proposes and then they literally go
through sickness and health together and
notice how that Ring Pop proposal it
seemed really endearing and touching
right that's because one of the writers
took that move directly from his brother
who proposed to his girlfriend the same
way so you can see the writers are
pulling out all the stops to give this
love story so much heart now when Wade
gets his cancer diagnosis the original
script went a slightly different
direction than the final cut does but
I'll get to that later ok moving back to
the freeway check out this shot when
Deadpool pulls the katanas back out of
the thug the camera pans down on him as
he holds the body up Tim Miller said
that he used the same shot as before
when the camera panned up and he just
reversed it and post now the fight
between Deadpool and Francis was
originally going to be way more
elaborate an early draft of the script
like there was going to be a high-speed
chase scene like from speed or the
Matrix Reloaded with the two of them
smashing through the rooms of a house
that's being transported on the back of
a truck it was gonna end with Francis
using a child as a human shield and the
Deadpool just like calling this bluff by
doing the same and yes this would have
been awesome to see but I get it limited
budget and honestly just seeing Deadpool
beat the crap out of Francis is
satisfying in its own way now notice how
Deadpool lifts his mask to reveal his
face to Francis how about now obviously
that line is reference to the 2004 comic
where Deadpool says he looks like Ryan
Reynolds crossed with a shar-pei
Reynolds has actually revealed that he's
been involved with bringing Deadpool to
the movies since 2004 he's also said
that the humor of Deadpool has
subconsciously inspired all of his
acting since then starting with blade
Trinity you know I
look back and I think wow that was I was
kind of in a weird way playing Wade
Wilson in that movie and I didn't know
it someone else did though they have
that's who sent me the comic book guy
new said your Deadpool and I read him
and I fell in love with it that was in
2004 when that panel came out of the
Deadpool comic that said asking whatever
what he looks like and he said I'm
across between Ryan Reynolds and Asher
hey I was sort of kismet I thought so if
you've loved Ryan Reynolds career for
the past decade we kind of have Deadpool
to thank since each of ryan reynolds
characters were channeling him in some
way now the junk cut out of the scene is
my favorite edit of the movie it goes
from Deadpool sideways in midair after
getting thrown by Colossus to the action
figure of the shitty x-men origins
Deadpool but I saw the movie this got
the biggest laugh and the theater also
got the biggest hiya second laughing so
the timing in the clever parallelism and
all these edits is a big reason why
flashbacks work and Deadpool so much
better than a movie like Suicide Squad
so with Deadpool a lot of thought
clearly went to this cut and the memory
was triggered by the characters
emotional state in the present day this
went sideways in the most colossal way
so Deadpool was just about to finally
get the satisfaction he wanted revenge
against Francis but it was snatched away
from him so it makes sense that we see a
parallel moment in Wade's past so close
to finally having a happy future with
Vanessa but cancer cruelly took it away
from him I think Suicide Squad tried to
do that but too often the flashbacks
just came in at random times and I don't
even know if the actor was thinking
about the memory when the audience saw
it it's like the editor just kind of
threw it in after the fact now if you
like Suicide Squad and you think I'm
being too hard on it you really should
check out Kyle's video where he brings
up a lot of solid points defending the
movie and it's weird
Joker dialogues you are my guests to
this handsome Hong Kong ha and I know
Deadpool and Suicide Squad are very
different movies with very different
goals but it kind of makes sense to
compare them just because they're both
stories about anti-heroes showing an
edgier but also more humorous side to
their movie universes and if you love
the not-so-good guys of the superhero
world just really anything at all about
the superhero world you really really
should check out loot crate you create
is a monthly subscription box service
that delivers a crate full of awesome
stuff right to you for less than $20 a
month just go to
great dot-com / rock stars each month as
a theme and this month's theme is you
guessed it antihero it's supposed to
have a lot of awesome Deadpool stuff too
so let's take a look all in months box
you have to sign up by the 19th of every
month at 9 p.m. Pacific if you use our
code rockstars
you get 10% on October's box's theme is
speed it's got a bunch of stuff from
like the flash and arrow all kinds of
great stuff in it and if you sign up for
loot crate right now you'll be eligible
for a special giveaway for new rockstars
this box that I just opened all you have
to do is sign up at loot crate comm
slash rockstars and tweet us your
favorite Easter egg and Deadpool
seriously guys I am a huge fan of loot
crate they do such great stuff for
youtubers like us so you really really
should sign up okay so let's get back to
Deadpool we're back in this scene in
Wade's apartment and there's all kinds
of little references if you're paying
attention specifically for me
I liked the Broadway references in the
scene with Wade's hearse with Bernadette
Peters on it she's a Broadway star and
that actually comes back later in the
movie I also like the subtle joke of
Wade wearing a rent shirt so just like
Wade a lot of the characters in the
musical Rent are slowly dying of a
terminal illness everyone has a
okay so moving on to this scene in the
bar and check out these pamphlets for
alternate cancer treatments sure they're
all FDA approved places like China and
Mexico Chechnya is that where you go to
get cancer so in an early draft of the
script we actually saw Wade travel
around the world trying to treat himself
by covering himself with snake guts in
India breathing herbal smoke in China
and experimental surgery in Mexico and
actually a deleted scene shows that last
one next ciient did with Wade killing a
corrupt Guadalajara surgeon for tricking
cancer patients this is actually where
Wade was originally going to abandon
Vanessa Wade an all explain why that was
changed in a second real quick though I
want to talk about this creepy Weapon X
recruiter guy so the movie compares him
to Agent Smith from the Matrix movies
but check out that phone number on his
car five five five low one nine nine now
if you've seen the movie American Beauty
Kevin Spacey's character has the same
number and it's interesting how both
characters are accused of being a little
creepy Spacey's character fantasize
about sleeping with an underage girl and
their recruiter for just having a
general pedophile vibe I guess look can
I help you besides luring children into
a panel van so let's look at this sad
scene the apartment with Wade deciding
to leave Vanessa Tim Miller chose to
make this the heartfelt turning point
instead of the deleted scene with the
doctor in Guadalajara now why did he do
that it's me as Miller didn't wanted to
seem like Wade was running away from a
crime and then turning to Weapon X
instead Wade's doing it for Vanessa in
this sincere moment in the apartment
illustrates that so much better okay so
moving on back to the freeway with
colossus and negasonic joining the mix
this scene has so much meta commentary
on superhero movies and there's really
nothing subtle about it let's pro/con
this superhero thing Pro lucrative film
deals both origin stories and larger
ensemble team movies today I decided to
become a crime-fighting Swizz ler who
rooms with a bunch of other little
whiners at the neverland mansion of some
creepy old bald heaven's gate looking
mother lets us go talk to the professor
McAvoy or Stewart these diamonds
using there's even an extended deleted
scene where Deadpool goes on a longer
rant about getting suckered into playing
Green Lantern yeah dollar money sure
nothing will be a superhero we don't
have a script yet but we promise it's
gonna be awesome
but what he doesn't say is that the
release date is totally unthinkable and
the super suit is M break up Saturday
morning cartoon yeah we all know that no
now if you look closely that deleted
footage you saw a pre CGI version of
Colossus so I just want to point out
that it took five actors to bring
Colossus to life one a body double for
motion capture in the studio - Andre
Trickett oh the guy we actually saw in
the footage he was the guy who did the
physical movement on set he's six nine
and he wore 8-inch stilts and a
headpiece to appear taller than three
they used a model for Colossus his
facial structure the crew actually
wanted to use the NFL player Rob
Gronkowski for this but it ended up not
coming together then for Greg glass all
the actor who created the facial
expressions for Colossus and then
finally five step on kappa check might
be saying that wrong he's the actor who
did the Russian accent voiceover no
other character that can be such as good
as contrast to Deadpool's character now
originally they were gonna have Daniel
Cudmore reprised apart from x2 and the
last stand but he backed out when they
told him that they were gonna have to
dub over his not tough enough voice I
can help you help him now there are
obviously references to all kinds of
things in the scene from Robocop Dead or
Alive you're coming with me
that are alive you are coming with me to
the Canadian national anthem o Canada
but I want to talk about how violent
Deadpool's fight with Colossus is so
seeing Deadpool tear each part of his
body off is the most viscerally
disturbing thing I have ever seen in a
superhero movie and I'm including with
Doctor Doom just popped everyone's heads
and Fantastic Four and the reason
Deadpool does this is not to be intense
or gritty they do it basically just to
send a middle finger to the whole
superhero movie formula you don't have
to be Disney fide and family-friendly
these are people with ridiculous
superpowers doing major damage to their
bodies so why do we have to shy away
from it let's just go way over the top
now I talked about Monty Python bits
earlier and Deadpool destroying his
limbs one by one is just like that bit
Holy Grail your stupid bastard you've
got the arms left yes I have look just a
flesh wound which the original script
actually called out and it's super gross
but I love it when Deadpool says are you
there God It's Me Margaret he's
referencing a story about a girl getting
her first period as blood sprays on
Colossus his face look awesome but then
we get another clever jump cut from this
overhead shot of Deadpool laying in the
garbage to a parallel shot of Wade
rolling into another garbage situation I
also want to point out the broken eggs
in the garbage truck it's a fun visual
foreshadowing of Francis's line of the
next scene
you've got the home Lincoln omelet break
some eggs bit my moving on to this
Weapon X lab Ryan Reynolds said that
this location is actually a former
munitions factory that makes it a
perfect setting for Weapon X which is a
factory that makes human shaped
munitions just like this mutant with
spikes sticking out of her back which
many of you pointed out is probably
marrow from the x-men comics now the
character of angel dust is actually a
replacement and a combination of three
henchmen that were in the original
script Sluggo
Kane and wire of course that would have
been more expensive especially with
Kane's Bionic shape-shifting arms but
really the writers just wanted to
simplify the antagonist of this story so
for that same reason they made Francis
slash Ajax the main villain even though
in the comics he's a subordinate to dr.
Killebrew he's the one who gets Deadpool
his powers in the comics and real quick
I want to point out this moment when
Wade gets as possible names for Ajax's
real name
what is it really Kevin Bruce Scott
Mitch now assuming that everything in
this movie is an easter egg because I'm
an insane person I think those could be
Marvel references to Kevin Feige Bruce
Banner Scott Summers and SHIELD agent
Mitch Carson who I know is a bit of a
deep cut but hey you know I I found a
Mitch so it's got to be connected right
and while I'm talking about connections
to Marvel characters check out how the
serum that Francis injects Wade with has
drops of blood in it now if you watch
the post-credits scenes of x-men
apocalypse there were those guys from
the Essex corporation that's mr.
sinister his company by the way picking
up a vial containing
Wolverine's blood now I wonder if the
drops of blood here belonged to
Wolverine and this is suggesting that
Wolverines regeneration powers are what
gave Deadpool is regeneration powers now
Wolverine and Deadpool belong to the
same Cinematic Universe so those guys
couldn't have being connected in the
future now I love the song choice here
of the Chordettes mr. Sandman the lyrics
are all about waking up to the perfect
man named the cute and that parallels
what weight is going through he's going
under hoping to wake up as the perfect
man cancer free for his loved one so
moving on to this scene with Cunningham
and if you read the comics you recognize
this guy as worm he's actually a much
bigger character in the comics he's the
one who comes up with a name Deadpool
they get from the death pool hand
weighed form in the lab now in the
comics Wade and worm have a very strong
connection during their time in the lab
so much so that Ajax tortures worm just
to get back and wait and then Wade puts
worm out of his misery by snapping his
neck and of course the movie doesn't get
into any of that backstory but we do get
this mini cold look between Wade and
worm as lab burns down and I think
that's why also these might have been
pretty obvious but I just love the
throwaway lines that made fun of the
other version of Deadpool where Fox
decided to be a good idea to sew the
mouth shut of a character whose nickname
is Merc with a mouth well show your
pretty mouth shut oh I wouldn't do that
if I were you sorry Francis my lips are
sealed
also notice that when Wade transforms
into his mutant state he says it's a
horror movie ah this is a reference to
Frankenstein which was considered one of
the first major novels in the horror
genre and obviously the parallels with
Wade becoming a freak of nature who has
to walk the earth alone hating his
scientist creator this is all very
Frankenstein now the writers said that
they aim to break down the runtime of
the movie so that one third of the movie
is spent with pretty boy Wade before his
experiments one third showing the
hideous Wade after his experience and
then another third showing Wade behind
the mask as Deadpool it's impressive
that this movie is so precise about the
stages of Wade's evolution into Deadpool
now before I talked about how in earlier
drafts Francis went to prison that's how
the fight in the fire was supposed to
end with Wade spending the five years of
Francis's prison
sentence becoming Deadpool and building
up his skills however Simon Kinberg who
is the big-time producer behind all the
x-men movies he suggested that Francis
win this fight and escape that would
make this loss for Wade feel even more
like a rock bottom moment and make the
revenge arc even more satisfying so
that's why when we see Wade crawl out of
the burnt rubble it's a literal phoenix
rising from the ashes moment now the
only thing I want to point out about
this sad scene on the rainy streets is
it was originally supposed to lead to a
much funnier section of the story with
Wade realising his power and trying to
kill himself over and over just like
that
suicide montage and Groundhog Day also
check out this shot of Wade walking into
the street it was cut early a deleted
scene shows us how it was supposed to
end now obviously this stuff is
hilarious but the writers had the
patience to know that for this movie to
work not everything in it can be sold
out for a joke so you've probably caught
all the Marvel references and this scene
with Wade and weasel coming up with
alternate superhero names Wade the
wisecracker or scare devil captain
Deadpool no just just dissed it well
yeah but there's a quick missable line
in here that seems like a really
specific reference to the movie Grosse
Pointe blank like I'm gonna put a bullet
hole before head of the brain I'll talk
sugar Morrow force him to fix this then
put a bullet in his skull and the brain
hole now one of the things I love about
Deadpool is that the humor isn't just
meta in a random way it uses inside
references from within the fan culture
that the character has inspired so the
best example of this is the use of the
Deadpool wrap by team head kick on
YouTube those guys wrote the rap in 2013
for the Deadpool video game and Tim
Miller liked it so much he had them
write a new version for the film dead
that is awesome so a few things I want
to point out during this amazing montage
the set designers filled the background
of weight department with pictures of
penises
you can actually see four hits is
wearing a crown of dicks on his wall in
the later scene you can see a rooster
aka a [ __ ] I love the set designers
working all that in I also know some
Deadpool at one point says he's using
the feminine form of Francis's name in
Spanish and this section played out
differently in other versions of the
movie so for example in the final cut
this is the first time we meet blind out
but in an early draft of the script she
appeared in the very first scene the
movie in a cutaway with her finding the
bag of guns that Deadpool accidentally
left at home also there's a deleted
scene that gave a christmas-themed to
this whole montage with Deadpool
counting down the days to Francis's
release with an advent calendar now this
section ends with Deadpool killing the
recruiter and check this out nice to see
you Jared I'll take footlong
fully loaded now this is another
pedophile joke referencing former subway
spokesman Jared Fogle who's now a
convicted pedophile and this is even
more interesting when you consider the
timing of this Deadpool wraps shooting
in May 2015
but the Fogle story didn't break until
later that summer that means they went
back to record this line in
post-production basically if you thought
the humor and Deadpool felt especially
sharp or fresh it's because Ryan
Reynolds - the writers went that extra
mile to punch up all the jokes
so this fast boarding gag was a great
meta moment
especially when it stopped on Deadpool
jerking off with the stuffed unicorn
whoops you weren't meant to see that
what's great about this is just like
that opening teabagging moment this
whole movie feels like Deadpool is just
screwing with us
like he recorded the story over his
personal sex tape and the fact that this
rebellious Deadpool spirit comes through
the editing and the structure of the
movie itself is what makes it such a fun
experience
so when Deadpool takes us into his
apartment with blind ow check out this
rag that he wraps his stump in and like
how it's already read meaning that it
may have blood from past fights and past
limbs everines
I also appreciated how blind owl is
listening to hit the road jack by Ray
Charles Ray Charles of course is a blind
singer okay so let's move on
Branch is his plan to cut up Deadpool so
much that there's nothing left of him to
heal brings up an interesting debate
fans have had about Deadpool since the
comics came out
how powerful exactly is his regeneration
wood cutting him up even kill him the
comics aren't totally clear on it
sometimes he can reattach a severed limb
sometimes he just grows a new limb
he's even grown a new head I think
before but I don't think the comics ever
want us to think too deeply about the
logic of this power I don't think the
movie does either so let's skip ahead to
this scene in the bar with angel does
seen the Polaroid of way to Vanessa
insane I've seen this girl now this
moment doesn't really elaborate but
that's interesting right like how would
ancient desks know Vanessa
of course Vanessa is a sex worker who
works in a strip club so maybe angel
dust is in the ladies but my theory is
that angel just knows Vanessa from the
Weapon X Lab and Vanessa is going to be
revealed as having her copycat powers in
a Deadpool sequel so moving on to this
scene in the strip club where we get the
gratuitous cameo promised to us in the
opening credits
give it up her chat Eddie and he may
have caught this but weasels line go get
her tiger
is the same final line of spider-man 2
okay I'm thinking depo actually says the
same line later in the movie okay so
obviously another huge laughs in the
movie is this moment when Deadpool shows
up to the x-men mansion and says this
line it's a big house it's funny that I
only ever see two of you it's almost
like the studio couldn't afford another
x-man of course I don't know how fair
that joke is like I don't really want to
see Wolverine and Cyclops and storm in
this movie what I love about it is that
it's true he does knock on the door of
the x-men mansion and no one else is
there to answer the door except one of
the teenage students at the school now a
lot of people pointed out that the
scrapyard vessel where the big climax
takes place looks a lot like a shield
Helicarrier like more the ones from the
Avengers or Captain America Winter
Soldier and creators of this movie
confirmed that that was the inspiration
but they couldn't call it out directly
because like the raft those helicarriers
are property of the MCU and Deadpool
belongs to a different studio and a
different Cinematic Universe moving on
it check out this shot with Deadpool
colossus and negasonic walking in slow
motion to DMX's x gonna give it to you
next Oh
[ __ ] way for you to get it on your own
ex no delivered to you this is another
one of those ex motifs that I talked
about earlier which makes sense because
this team-up moment is the closest
Deadpool has gotten to being a true
member of the x-men I also really like
how the lyrics stainless steel syncs up
with this shot of Colossus staying still
now in the old script this whole
showdown was supposed to take place in a
tall high-rise with the team taking out
each of the three sub bosses Sluggo Kane
and wire on a different floor on their
way up to Francis kind of like the
movies the raid or attack the block but
when the writers simplified the villains
into angel dust and Francis a stages
instead in this scrapyard and actually I
feel like that could be a reference to
the awesome gritty fight scene from
Superman 3 now we're in the third act
here so I'm gonna skip over a lot of the
obvious stuff and just kind of point out
the things that I found really
interesting so negasonic is the first
x-men character on film to actually wear
the colors that are consistent with the
comics in the animated show now that's
actually been a long battle between fans
of the comics and director Bryan Singer
who prefers to dress up the x-men in
these black leather jumpsuits for
whatever reason Wiesel actually call
that out earlier in the movie you want
any clothes that are not monochromatic
but Tim Miller insisted on the blue and
yellow colors and hey what do you know
it doesn't look so bad so hopefully
those more colorful costumes that we saw
the end of x-men apocalypse are here to
stay
I also like how Deadpool makes this
promise to Francis what's my name
I'm a spell it out for you and the
Deadpool just tears apart everyone even
stopping a teabag this one guy echoing
the moment at the beginning of the movie
and then he literally uses their body
parts to spell out Francis I love that
if you look closely you can see that
he's pulled down the pants of one of the
guys to moon Francis so great there's
also a quick cameo by Hydra Bob Bob wait
so in the comics Hydra Bob is kind of a
recurring sidekick figure to Deadpool
and they call him Bob here because Hydra
is say together an MCU property I also
like this quick reference to the dark
night here where Francis says choice of
words very poor choice of words
now at the end of this fight notice the
timing of Colossus four or five moments
speech four or five moments I'm sorry
four or five moments that's all it takes
now there's a reason this works so well
Tim Miller wanted the audience to get a
little ahead of the punchline so notice
how the camera cuts away from Colossus
to Deadpool and Francis exchanging this
look so right here we know Colossus is
not gonna finish a speech and I love
this take a look at Colossus vomit it's
got this silver metallic texture to
Miller reason that when Colossus changes
into his metallic form the contents of
his stomach change in a metal - so we
all love this Hugh Jackman face at the
end of the movie and not to over explain
the joke too much but it's structured
perfectly Deadpool kind of warns Vanessa
that he's gonna be ugly is a hideous
monster the guy out of this mask he
ain't the same one that you remember but
then what does Vanessa see when she
takes off the mask the People magazine
cover for sexiest man alive
and then when Deadpool says to Colossus
tailed beast - stop yeah my lauding that
joke was originally supposed to lead to
a cutaway with Nicholas Hoult as the
Beast taking a dump on Deadpool's front
lawn and then running away but
unfortunately they couldn't schedule
time for hold to come in and shoot it
now raking down the post-credits scene
yes it's an awesome throwback to one of
the first ever post-credit scenes Ferris
Bueller's Day Off with Deadpool teasing
cable coming in the sequel this sequel
we're gonna have cable so cable is a
badass superhero from the x-men and
Deadpool comics he has this like bionic
arm and his storyline travels through
time in so many complicated ways
victus backstory is super complex he's
technically
the son of Scott Summers and a version
of Jean Grey it's super insane I don't
know how much of it is gonna make it in
the movie but the cable and Deadpool
team-up series in the comics is amazing
they're kind of the perfect buddy-cop
duo in the Marvel Comics we don't know
who's gonna be playing cable yet some
people are pulling for Ron Perlman or
Stephen Lang or maybe Jeffrey Dean
Morgan
Robert life field actually mocked up
this photo of Jon Hamm is cable hidden
yeah I think I could get down with Don
Draper as cable okay that is everything
I got and again I know there are a ton
of little references and easter eggs in
this movie that I didn't point out but
at this point I feel like you guys
probably saw a lot of those so if you
like this video please hit like and
subscribe to new rockstars and then
share this video with your friends you
can also support us by becoming a patron
on patreon to all of our current patrons
thank you so much you guys are so great
and we actually have some really cool
benefits that are coming up for just our
patrons coming up soon so keep an eye
out for those and thank you again for
continuing to support us so if you want
more updates on our videos you can
follow us at new rock stars on Twitter
and you can follow me on Twitter at EA
vos and tweet at me any theories or
questions that you had all right thanks
for watching guys bye next Oh give it to
you but wait for you to get it on your
own external delivery
open up the door to scram the nonstop
from stainless there go hard getting
busy with it I got such a good